Памятник Фальц-Фейну
у нас появился не так давно...
Ім’я Фрідріха Фальц-Фейна тут, в Асканії-Нова
промовляють з особливою шаною
Адже німецький природознавець
у засушливому степу Херсонщини
виростив парк, посадив сотні видів рослин
та завіз з усього світу рідкісних диких тварин
Зокрема врятував від вимирання
дикого коня Пржевальського
що нині став візитівкою заповідника
Родина Фальц-Фейна - нащадки
так званих "російських німців"
що приїхали до колишньої Російської імперії
заселяти дикі території
Зовсім мало знав про свого земляка Фальц-Фейна
німецький дослідник Бертрам фон Боксберґ
Лише дати народження та смерті
Бертрам - прес-секретар берлінського кладовища
де похований засновник українського заповідника
На пам'ятнику стоїть дата, коли він жив
І нижче стоїть: засновник Асканія-Нова
І я завжди думав, що ж таке Асканія-Нова
Сафарі українським півднем
Ми поїдемо на ту сторону, це не бєзопасно
ми їх об’їжжать будем
Серед африканських бізонів
оленів
та рідкісних сайгаків
Поїздку до України Бертрам
запланував невдовзі після того
як в місцевій берлінській газеті
випадково натрапив на матеріал про Асканію-Нова
та про його засновника
Вже тоді зрозумів, що час налагоджувати
втрачені понад сто років тому контакти
У своїх цілях упевнився, вже коли побачив заповідник на власні очі
Я дуже вражений цим парком,
це просто вищий пілотаж
коли ось так з нічого виростає цілий парк
Гаразд, в Берліні це нормально
є парк і він поливається водою
Але ж тут це посеред степу
Все дуже тонко зроблено
Це справді першокласна робота
Бертрам під час сафарі робить чимало світлин
Після повереня у Німеччину
чоловік хоче розповісти про унікальний парк місцевій громаді
Директор заповідника мріє,
що німці зацікавляться артефактами
як ось цим найстарішим будиночком
Йому вже 200 років,
а грошей на реконструкцію немає
Цей будиночок повністю зберігся
ми його законсервували для того,
щоб його ніхто не зруйнував
Ми хотіли б зробити табір молодіжних волонтерів
екологічних волонтерів
Щоб сюди приїздили
дітки із Західної Європи
і співпрацювали з нашими
Ім’я науковця, який заснував на півдні України
найбільший в Європі біосферний заповідник
мало відоме в Німеччині, каже Бертрам
Так само як і Асканія-Нова
Тож можливо його дослідження прокладуть
і нові маршрути для німецьких туристів
Адже степ площею з Мюнхен
на якому вільно пасуться дикі та рідкісні тварини
унікальне явище для європейського мандрівника